what's your nature of your friendship
with eric weinstein how did the two how
did such two interesting paths cross is
it
your origins in physics is it your
interest in philosophy and the ideas of
how the world works what is it it's
actually it's very random it's uh eric
found me um he actually found travis uh
and and i um
elephant yeah we were both working at a
company called nthot uh back in the mid
2000's and we're doing
a lot of consulting around scientific
python um and we'd made some some tools
and uh eric was trying to use some of
these python tools to visualize he had a
fiber bundle approach to
modeling certain aspects of economics he
was doing this and that's how he kind of
got in touch with us and so
um this was in the early this is the
mid-2000s uh
07 time frame oh 607 eric weinstein
trying to use python right
fiber bundles uh using some of the tools
that we've built in the open source
that's somehow entertaining to me
it's pretty funny but then um you know
we met with him a couple times a really
interesting guy and then in the wake of
the o708 kind of financial collapse he
uh helped organize with lee smullen
a symposium at the perimeter institute
about um okay well clearly
you know big finance can't be trusted
governments in its pockets would
regularly capture what the f do we do
and all sorts of people nasim talib was
there and uh andy lowe from mit was
there and you know uh bill jainway i
mean just a lot of you know top billing
people were there and he invited me and
travis and uh another one of her
co-workers uh robert kern who is a
anyone in the scipy numpy community
knows robert
really great guy so the three of us also
got invited to go to this thing and
that's where i met brett weinstein for
the first time as well
yeah i knew him before he got all famous
for unfortunate reasons i guess but uh
but but anyway we um
so we met then and kind of had a
friendship um you know throughout
since then you have a depth of thinking
that uh kind of runs with eric in terms
of just thinking about the world deeply
and thinking philosophically and then
there's eric's interest in programming i
actually never
um
you know he'll bring up programming to
me quite a bit as a metaphor for stuff
right but i never kind of pushed the
point of like
what's the nature of your interest in
programming i think you saw it probably
as a tool yeah absolutely that to
visualize to explore mathematics and
explore physics but and i was wondering
like what's the
his uh depth of interest and also his
uh
vision for what programming
would look like in the future have you
have you had interaction with him like
discussion in the space of python no
programming well um in the sense of
sometimes you ask me why is this stuff
still so hard
um
uh yeah you know everybody's a critic
but uh but actually no eric programming
you mean like yes yes well not
programming in general but certain
things in the python ecosystem
but he uh but he actually i think what i
find in listening some of his stuff is
that he does uh use programming
metaphors a lot right he'll talk about
apis or object oriented and things like
that so i think that's a useful
set of frames for him to draw upon for
uh discourse um i haven't paired
programmed with him in a very long time
you've you've previously well i mean
trying to try to help like put together
some of the visualizations around these
things but it's been a
very not really pair program but like
even looked at his code right i mean how
legendary would be is that like uh get
repo
with peter wang and eric weinstein well
honestly honestly robert kearn did all
the heavy lifting so i have to give
credit where credit is due robert is is
the silent but incredibly deep um quiet
not silent but quiet but incredibly deep
individual at the heart of a lot of
those things that eric was trying to do
um but we did have you know in the
as travis and i were starting our
company in um
2012 time frame
we went to new york eric was still in
new york at the time he hadn't moved to
this is before he joined teal capital we
just had like a steak dinner somewhere
maybe it was keane's i don't know
somewhere in new york so it's me travis
eric and then wes mckinney the creator
of pandas and then wes is um then
business partner adam the five is sat
around having this just a
hilarious time amazing dinner um i
forget what all we talked about but it
was it was one of those conversations
which i wish um as soon as covet is over
maybe eric and i can sit down recreate
recreate it somewhere in uh in l.a or
maybe he comes here because a lot of
cool people here in austin right exactly
yeah we're all here from here come here
you